Please welcome, Naomie Harris.
(audience applause)
(Naomie laughing)
Hi, sweetheart.
You're so beautiful.
Aw, thank you.
As are you.
My goodness.
Drool.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, you're so beautiful.
And you're so incredibly talented.
I have loved you in so many different
incredible iterations and films,
and God, you've really tackled zombies and pirates,
and, you know, now this.
We've actually been talking about all things earth
and you're in "The Man Who Fell to Earth",
which is the classic David Bowie film.
If he's not the sexiest man that ever lived,
I don't know who is.
And so talented.
He's amazing in that film.
It's like his film debut and he's incredible in that movie.
Everything he did, he turned into gold.
He's the most magnanimous man.
So I love that this film is not a remake.
It's like a leave off and move forward,
which is so interesting-
Yeah, 45 years after the original film was made.
Yeah.
It's just, there's no rules.
We can get so creative in the film world or television world
with storytelling.
And I love that this film picks up where it left off.
And you're doing it with Chiwetel Ejiofor,
who is just such an amazing actor.
Phenomenal.
And nominated as well for Academy Awards.
But is it true that you guys used to date in real life?
Oh my gosh, this is your first question to me, Drew.
Geez.
Wow.
Yeah, I never ever talk about my private life.
I have to say that.
But your researcher, I have to say,
she is incredible because we've been doing
so much press and nobody else has spotted this.
Nobody else.
Yes!
Except your show, and your amazing researcher.
Yeah, we were in our twenties.
It was a long time ago.
I feel like I revisited a few exes in the last few years.
Kind of as friends, like where are we at now?
I also was like, it was my fault,
everything was my fault and I will revisit them
and I'm like, oh, you're still doing that thing too.
Okay, interesting.
Great.
Maybe it was 50/50.
Cool.
Yeah, well, it definitely wasn't like that with Chiwetel.
I mean, like we were so young and it was really
a brief kind of thing and we were mainly just friends
to be honest.
And then we saw each other again making this
and we've stayed in contact since, and you know,
it was really easy and fun
and there were no awkward moments whatsoever.
I like working with exes.
Like, Tom Green came on this show.
I think it's fun.
You're probably like, where is this all going?
I came on the show and here I am bringing out the ex files.
But I'm very excited for this project.
(upbeat music)